es gibt keine teilchen und es ist noch
schlimmer es gibt kein mathematisches
modell das in der teilchenphysik so
heißt sie nämlich trotzdem
paradoxerweise also mit dem richtig
gerechnet werden kann noch immer tab die
physik da ziemlich im dunkeln wie bitte
die haben eigentlich keine ahnung von
dem was sie da machen allerdings gibt es
einen lichtblick korrelation klicks hans
im future die gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonnieren den
kanal und aktivität glocke nur so
verfallen und los geht's
herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist entstanden in
kooperation mit riedle de den digitalen
abos für smartphone oder tablet für nur
regulär 99 gibt es nahezu alle magazine
und zeitschriften der link ist hier
unter mit einem besonders günstigen
sonderangebot für euch hier unter dem
link gibt es die ersten beiden monate
für zusammen nur einen euro 99 ab dann
999 und es kann jederzeit gekündigt
werden und wir haben dieses mega
spannende thema dort auf wdr.de in
spektrum der wissenschaft gefunden und
dort kann ich sogar noch in bis zu vier
jahre alten ausgaben recherchieren ich
habe sie immer alle dabei ohne einen
schweren rucksack mit mir rumschleppen
zu müssen und kann mir schnell zu jedem
thema lesezeichen an den entsprechenden
stellen setzen das ist wirklich einfach
mega und das ist wirklich zu mäuse
melken physik geht nicht ohne mathematik
und in der quantenphysik kommen die
fachleute einfach auf keinen grünen
zweig nichts funktioniert so richtig und
im gegenteil sie landen mit ihren
ergebnissen immer wieder in der
unendlichkeit die müssen sich echt zu
fühlen wie ich in einer mathe klausur
immer kommen wie der ergebnisse heraus
die nicht stimmen können woran liegt das
große problem das sind alles gar keine
teilchen und das macht es extrem
schwierig während man zum beispiel ein
zwei kugeln zusammenstoßen ziemlich
genau berechnen kann was passiert und
welche kugel danach wohin rollt oder
fliegt geht das bei der quantenphysik
und das obwohl die phänomene oder wie
wir sie hier wahrnehmen die teilchen nur
ganz bestimmte eigenschaften annehmen
können das geht da nicht sie sind
quantifiziert der drehimpuls eines
teilchens nur ganz bestimmte werte
annehmen irgendetwas dazwischen wie 123
47 oder ähnlich geht einfach nicht dass
es super simpel allerdings gibt es in
der quantenphysik
wahrscheinlichkeiten alles geschieht mit
einer wahrscheinlichkeit sehr gut ist
dass in gedanken experiment mit
schrödingers katze beschrieben sie sitzt
in einer kiste mit einem atom das
zerfällt wenn es zerfällt wird es die
katze umbringen da das atom aber mit
einer wahrscheinlichkeit zerfällt ist
die katze mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit
tot beziehungsweise lebendig sie schwebt
de facto in einem zwischenzustand und
erst wenn wir in die kiste reinschauen
also messen steht fest ob das atom
zerfallen ist und die katze lebt oder
gestorben ist das ist quantenphysik und
das ganze basiert auf feldern wenn also
neue teilchen gefunden werden da sind
dass eben keine teilchen sondern ein
feld und stoßen zwei teilchen zusammen
dann passieren eben genau das nicht
sondern zwei felder interagieren
miteinander und das ist wirklich absolut
verrückt denn die konsequenzen sind
ziemlich beeindruckend so sind alle
protonen absolut gleich egal ob sie
soeben bei einer kollision im large
hadron collider lhc am cern in genf
entstanden sind oder vor 10 milliarden
jahren sie sind fluktuationen des
gleichen kanten feldes und diese
fluktuation kann es auch mitten im
vakuum geben so genannte vakuum
fluktuation dabei entstehen zwei
teilchen zum beispiel ein protonen und
antiprotonen die also entgegengesetzt
geladen sind und löschen sich direkt
danach sofort wieder außer das passiert
am ereignishorizont eines schwarzen
loches da kann das eine teilchen hinter
dem ereignishorizont erscheint und das
andere davor und während das eine
teilchen ins schwarze loch gezogen wird
kann das andere teilchen entfliehen die
sogenannte hawking strahlung die am ende
dazu führt dass das schwarze loch
verschwindet so die theorie von stephen
hawking braucht das ist schon alles
ziemlich verrückt und zwar so verrückt
dass die mathematik nicht
hinterherkommen bisher entstanden aus
beobachtungen der physik auch immer neue
mathematische gebiete so zum beispiel
die trigonometrie aus der beobachtung
der sterne durch die alten griechen vor
rund 2000 jahren oder vor rund 300
jahren die infinity sie mal die unter
anderem zur berechnung von
planetenbahnen benötigt wird fehlt her
also auch eine neue mathematik
jedenfalls stehen die forschung vor
nahezu unlösbaren aufgaben wenn sie die
fluktuation in einem feld an einem
bestimmten punkt berechnen wollen landen
sie war etwas monströses es ist nicht
ein wer zum beispiel wie die temperatur
an einem bestimmten ort es sind tabellen
und die haben achtung festhalten
unendlich viele spalten und zeilen wo
hat die fluktuation kann ja überall im
kranken fällt seit wie soll man denn
damit rechnen können und genau das geht
auch nicht will man jetzt nämlich zum
beispiel den zusammenprall von zwei
teilchen also zwei fluktuationen im lhc
berechnen dann muss man diese beiden
tabellen miteinander multiplizieren und
dabei entstehen zahlreiche ergebnisse
die unendlich sind um es mal salopp zu
formulieren das ist mist doch die
forschung haben eine lösung gefunden bzw
eine notlösung die näherung sie nähern
sich langsam dem ergebnis und sind damit
schon relativ genau nämlich auf 13
nachkommastellen allerdings ist das nur
ein hilfsmittel wie viele andere auch
und unser universum ist damit nicht
umfassend beschrieben und auch andere
herangehensweisen führen lediglich zu
näherung an verfahren ist zum beispiel
die pid methode eigentlich sind die
felder in der quantenphysik
kontinuierlich bei der guitar eich
methode wird aber ein grobes gitter über
das feld gelegt und auch hier bedient
man sich dann der nehrung und macht das
gitter enger und fügt immer mehr kita
linie zusammen mit einem beweis dass das
feld dem näherungswert der guitar
entspricht hat man dann eine
funktionierende methode doch all das ist
letztlich muss es ist so ein bisschen
als würde man mit einem taschenmesser
eine schraube fest drehen es geht aber
es passt nicht richtig damit ist die
quantenphysik oder die theorie ihrer
felder die quantenfeldtheorie in einer
etwas unglücklichen lage wir finden
immer wieder beweise und wir arbeiten
sogar konkret mit ihr wir haben sogar
schon maschinen gebaut die mit
quantenphysik funktionieren wie zum
beispiel apparate für die
magnetresonanztomographie wir wissen
also dass es die quaken für sie gibt und
dass sie auch so funktioniert allerdings
können wir sie immer noch nicht
mathematisch so beschreiben dass die
mathematik dazu ein werkzeug ist das
universell 1 zwar ist die vier
dimensionale raum zeit scheint so nicht
beherrschbar und damit manifestiert sich
noch eine weitere lücke wo ist die
gravitation in der quantenphysik und das
ist auch einfach nur ärgerlich werden
wir sie inzwischen zuverlässig messen
können haben wir das quanten fällt dazu
noch nicht gefunden während die zu den
anderen drei grund kräften dem
elektromagnetismus der schwachen und der
starken kernkraft bekannt sind es ist
wirklich zum mäuse melken und dabei
führen den mathematischen bemühungen zu
ergebnissen die absolut beeindruckend
sind auch die stringtheorie die ja von
fäden in einem vierdimensionalen raum
ausgeht und unser universum erklären
könnte ist daran beteiligt dort haben
zwei unterschiedliche ansätze die auf
unterschiedlichen geometrischen räumen
basieren zu der gleichen langen liste
von zahlen geführt die mathematik der
quantenfeldtheorie führt also bereits zu
absolut frappierenden erkenntnissen
allerdings führt sie letztlich zu keinem
ergebnis aber vielleicht sehen die
forscher auch vor lauter bäumen den wald
nicht diesen ansatz verfolgt kevin
costello vom perimeter institute for
theoretical physics in waterloo kanada
er sagt dass man zunächst herausfinden
muss welche werte in der quantenphysik
andere werte beeinflussen also wie
bestimmte werte miteinander korrelieren
es war kann auch er noch immer nicht das
vieh dimensionale universum beschreiben
aber immerhin können seine
quantenfeldtheorie einen geometrischen
raum mit entsprechenden korrelation
funktionen beschreiben das thema stammt
übrigens aus riedle de ich nutze die app
echt schon ewig weil auf wikileaks
einfach alles und das viel ausführlicher
als im netz wie zum beispiel hier
quantenfeldtheorie das fundament der
physik in spektrum der wissenschaft
allein für dieses magazin und sie schon
das video aber es gibt noch weitere 5000
magazin und mehr auf wti das
sonderangebot für euch gibt es hier
einfach draufklicken der link ist
übrigens auch in der video beschreibung
und als erster kommentaren gewinnt dass
es ein echter mehrwert also drauf
klicken und los geht's bis dann bleibt
dran